that's the end of season through you
want you're not washed characters wash
up on the shores of America
what happens then oui oui yes season
four we you know we are in America and
we are these basically immigrants you
know Jamie is has always wanted to have
his family around him and to be a
layered and here he has that opportunity
to really build a life for them and so
it's the first time we get to see Jamie
Claire really sort of operating as a
family unit and and Jamie you know being
this patriarch yeah do we do have
faithful season four is to the book
quite faithful we've always stuck pretty
faith you out to the books there are
gonna be some little little surprises
for fans of the books as well but yeah
pretty pretty much where we sort of do
like to stick to them you know dinah
goblins written this this wealth of of
novels for us so we're very lucky to
have that are there time travel kiosks
in America I can't think of a better way
to write Doctor Who yeah doctor who's
TARDIS is all over yeah are there like
point there are there must be points
though right is there or one or some
well I think we gave away in season
three you know that there's more than
one stone circle so to speak so you may
see more in season four love is hard
isn't it I mean this is this is one of
those things in real life it really is
but I mean I think one of the things
that you must take away from is that if
these people keep coming back together
that truly is I mean is these are
soulmates
in this story yeah yeah absolutely and
you know it's the first time in season
four where we they are you know finally
not being you know attacked by redcoats
or or you know sort of on the run from
someone so yeah it is a real a real
moment for them to sort of establish
some roots and and sort of build this
base but overarching all over that you
know we know the history of America and
Jamie you know to to build this this
this base he has to establish some some
ties with his sworn enemy you know the
Redcoats the the British so you know we
know the history of America we know
where it's headed and and that is you
know there's great battles over the you
know Wars of Independence so
that is certainly on the horizon some
people in this story because of time
travel know the future you couldn't
possibly have foreseen what was going to
happen without land or when you signed
on looking back on it how do you feel
about it yeah it's uh it's been an
incredible journey you know and you know
here we are on the studios in the
studios in Scotland and four years ago
this was you know an empty warehouse and
we felt you know it felt very new and
very very fresh and we had no real idea
of you know where this show was gonna go
and we've been in all over the world
we've been to different different
countries shooting and it's been
incredible to see this family grow and I
think that's what really what we have
and certainly this season you know the
family has grown a lot so yeah we feel
very fortunate to still be playing these
characters but to seen them grown as
well
it's kept you fit you've had to stay fit
you know see this or do in season three
now we're doing season four you're like
no I can't I can't take a break from
working out it is uh well I don't know I
think you know Jamie's not ready to
retire I think that's there's younger
ones there you know but um no it is it
is a you know a great show that it does
take a long time for us to shoot so you
know we apologize for the dry land area
you know that does take a while between
seasons but as you can see it's it's a
massive show and it does take time but
that makes the heart grow fonder
hopefully yes and and our friends do
keep coming back and and we seem to be
attracting more fans as well now so we
feel very lucky you know they seem to be
with you through thick and thin though
they they're just your fanbase is
incredibly loyal they are super loyal
and I think we have really to thank
Diana Gabaldon for you know for her book
series but what also sure you know has
gathered its own fans from the show and
I think it's it's interesting I think
people also have been discovering it
throughout the years so you know even
this last year we seem to have gathered
you know a real a real big strong fan
base in the UK so it's um just seem like
this sort of rolling rolling ball well
you you your character will get to meet
his daughter for the first time and I
think I can't was tell me you haven't I
know I'm not spoiling it spoiler alert
nothing but on this set working up to
that that's got to be you've got to be
anticipating it's gonna be that's a huge
moment that everybody's working towards
this I think it for Jamie it's gonna be
a defining moment yeah
you know he he's got this family around
him he's he's always he's never had his
own children around him you've got his
sort of surrogate son Fergus and his you
know Ian who's you know his his own
blood but for him to finally meet his
daughter it's gonna be really
interesting we haven't shot that yet but
you know he's he's obviously seen
pictures of her but he's never met her
and I think that's gonna be a really big
moment you mentioned pictures he didn't
deal very well with the bikini photo I'm
just wondering there's that bikini
photos that's scratching the surface
he better not turn up in a bikini
there'll be trouble you'll be grounded
for weeks if that is one of the great
things about the show isn't it that that
kind of like forcing kind of
modernizations on people who aren't
quite ready for it yet yeah and I think
that's what's great about em you know
Jamie he's always learning from Claire
you know and sort of the values of her
world and the future and she's always
learning from him as well but yeah I
think we're lucky you know I think it
wouldn't have worked if he was quite so
stuck in yeah time zone you know he is
he is a very forward-thinking man and
but yeah when it comes to bikinis and
his daughter I think cover yourself yes
Natalia you're obviously people love the
love scenes do they get easier do they
get is it more difficult the same as in
season one doing the love scenes as you
get older you get more experienced you
learn to take your time no and they get
hotter no it's a it's a it's it's you
know it's never easy yeah but that's
been interesting you know they're
obviously a really big part of the show
and of the relationship between Jamie
and Claire and we've always tried to
make each one different and move the
characters forward and where they are in
their relationship and and right now you
know in season four they are you know
this this this couple that have really
laying down roots and sort of living
this this family life that's we've never
had a chance to do that so now I'm not
going to ask you how steamy the scenes
are because now you're talking about
true love and the family being together
and all that stuff so we'll move on we
don't have to talk about it cuz I just
had to ask kind of the steamy meter how
steamy were they from 0 to 10 but we'll
say their families the families yes even
sounds worse maybe I'm not sure
there is your piece I mentioned that
fans will follow you no matter what
you're doing the my peak challenge is
quite spectacular now thank you and
that's what what an amazing side benefit
yeah
to what you've been able to the
notoriety you've been able to achieve
yeah it's been a people that don't know
it's some charity fundraiser that we
started a couple years ago on social
media and we've we've really grown in
this year we've pasta a million dollars
raised for for our chosen charity and
we're expanding we have we have you know
thousands of our pkers now are on this
subscription service and they receive
workout schedules and meal plans but the
bigger picture is that you know there's
this charity aspect to it and we've been
able to support a couple of charities
and fund some finance projects so
research projects so it's been a yeah
really rewarded 2018 going strong that's
amazing